honestly just watching this movie I just
can't help but be struck by the deep
deep irony that exists in the delay of
this film
and I just I mean it makes me wonder
like when that conversation came up what
was your first reaction to it just
knowing what the movie was very meta
I mean maybe is about cancelled culture
and it got cancelled it was very very
meta as it was happening we were all
just like this is the movie I was
looking up her arrows because I'm like
this is what's happening sorry
I mean was there any hesitation like
when that idea was brought up like did
you kind of go with it knowing that it
didn't fit the matically with the movie
yo yeah I definitely if I had it to do
over again and could get what I wanted I
would not have that movie out the
schedule I mean that's not it was not it
was no part of it was happy but except
that I'm glad the movies finally coming
out yeah people certainly wished it
would have come out in September people
can finally see it now judge for
themselves yeah I think it was pretty
insane it's the most meta advertising
campaign we could have asked for I also
think knowing that the world moves so
fast and that the Internet is such a you
know can be a garbage fire and that to
just breathe and put our phones down and
look at the horizon for a little while
was probably the best solution it was
just an incredibly surreal experience
because that you know as the controversy
was happening I was saying but it was
just a joke like the movie's supposed to
be fun and then realizing oh these are
things that characters in the movie
actually say no one's gonna believe when
they see this movie that we didn't read
all this material but for a movie that's
about kind of being misunderstood or
went or a misunderstanding going just
like extreme absurdity that's that's
what it sort of felt like I mean
obviously we were taking it very
seriously as it was was happening but
now that the movie is finally coming out
I I you know I I hope to have much more
of a sense of humor about it and I
understand it didn't change at all in
the last six months we changed nothing
yeah not a frame not one frame well one
word not one frame no it was very
important to me that we released we
talked about it obviously but I wanted
to release exactly the movie they were
intending on releasing in September and
that's what's getting released and just
I mean one thing that really struck me
about this film is that it is very much
a horror comedy like it is in equal
pairing just as
if it as it is really funny and that is
comport and parcel with the satire I'm
curious just about the process of like
basically managing that tone throughout
the production and especially with you
just knowing your comedic background and
the fact that you are mostly playing it
straight just kind of your process to
the character you know Craig's level is
an amazing director and we discussed it
aloud we had a couple Skype calls when
we kind of talked about what this guy's
kind of roots are and why he ended up
here and who he is and we got this big
conversation about how you want to reach
for him because you don't know where he
is and then kind of where he lands and I
just kind of trust him so much he's so
great with actors I know if you ever
seen the movie compliance but like it's
an incredibly powerful movie where he
got actors do crazy things and then when
you talk to him for a few minutes he
just makes you so calm and lets you
really kind of shine so I really give
credit to Craig's elbow for for shaping
that character level in post-production
it was quite a it was an act of
balancing to make sure like you know
when are we when are we allowed to go
into a comedic moment or when can we use
the communica moment to undercut some
sort of action or horror beat the goal
was really to make something absurd and
fun and so the hope was that we would
kind of you know consistently pursue
that right yeah we kept I think kind of
keep churning back to the game to the
hut that was what was our sort of one of
our I think beacons sort of in figuring
out what the most really was like there
was there's sort of moments that when it
sort of felt suss that it's strayed too
much from that you actually just wanted
to be back on that roller coaster
because it's so many twists and turns
and like that's sort of the heart of the
movie and that's where it was in a sweet
spot yeah I mean I think horror and
comedy share a lot you know it gets a
physical reaction in the whether you
jump or a laugh and and and there's
there's a lot of scary movies have the
insidious movies are 30% jokes you know
between between specks and Tucker and
and it actually makes I think that makes
the movies scary when you when you're
laughing you're kind of relaxing and
you're more susceptible to being scared
yes and actually just I do want to ask
about kind of crystals emotional state
in this film because obviously a lot of
characters are freaked out but when we
first see her she's making a compass
she's already like doing her thing to
get transferred
I'm just kind of curious about kind of
mod like metering her emotional status
because she's also kind of always on
that level yes totally yeah I think that
Krystal probably you know I think it's
it's difficult because almost talking
about what's going on in Crystal's brain
to me is a spoiler because I think that
it's fun as an audience member to kind
of decide for yourself who Krystal is
and what's going on with her I will say
I thought a lot about what Krystal is
like in normal circumstances and
probably you know at the DMV she's the
weirdest person in the room but in this
strange apocalyptic circumstance it kind
of matches what's going on in her brain
so she's more at home here than she is
at a baby shower she does need to renew
her registration now yeah eventually
she's gonna lizard yeah actually I mean
just a part of that I feel I feel like
the jackrabbit and box tortoise story is
very informative about kind of where she
comes from I'm just curious like that's
a very different take on the tortoise in
the hair that I've ever heard of where'd
it come from and just how did it inform
your performance well for every
character I try to think of no matter
whether shanwa is finding the Greek
circumstances because you know I like to
play high stakes even if those stakes
are sort of muffled to be in a scene you
know about laundry of which I do many as
I couldn't imagine a higher state what
if a pink sock gets in yeah yeah so you
know the Jackrabbits story to me is
about a feeling that is similar to that
where if you feel like you're supposed
to be a revolutionary or the hero in
your own story and then somewhere along
the way you lose your way or the
circumstances of your life don't match
those Greek circumstances that you feel
inside I think a lot of us feel that way
where you know we're bred to be warriors
and then you're sitting in traffic or
your iPhone update has erased all your
contacts you're like what embarrassing
circum
chances for a gladiator like myself to
be in and I think yes yeah and I think
that this movie however horrifying the
circumstances are it's really sort of
crystals chance to actualize in a really
demented way yeah certainly when Nick
and I wrote that scene the I one of the
messages of the movie is that we're not
gonna give you a message and I think
that we all hear these Aesop's fables at
The Tortoise and the hare
and I always sort of thought like this
is a horrible moral which is basically
like if you just keep on keepin on but
it only works if the person that you're
racing against is incredibly arrogant
and likes to take naps and in the real
world that person if they lost they
there would be vengeance yeah and so
let's just you know I'm always curious
what happens after the fable so if
anything that scene illustrates what
happens when you truck when you wag your
finger at someone and try to teach them
a lesson your finger might find itself
getting bitten off so I'm always curious
just about the evolution of projects and
going from the first draft of this to
what we see in the finished cut which
way would you say how would you say that
it kind of changed the most over time
the first yeah I mean I think I think
that the first the the draft that we
sort of that ever that anyone saw
besides Damon and I was pretty similar
to what the final movie was yeah we did
at the end there's a big fight sequence
and we just sort of said this is gonna
be a crazy fight sequence so Craig was
hugely responsible for I think turning
it into something that was actually more
than a sentence on a page so that that
changed it was born and I think that you
know as we watched the movie I was lucky
to be there on set and Craig and I were
sort of constantly trying to respond in
small ways to like what we were seeing
from the performances and stuff and
finessing things but for sure I would
say that like the actors you know
especially you know Betty and Hillary
but truly like all of the actors kind of
brought I think everybody knew what we
were trying to do and was we were all
kind of lockstep and trying to like
achieve that and and amuse each other
everyday and so there was some level
where I felt like it you know you read
something like that's funny that works
and then all of a sudden in
making of it you know you have this
other voice that comes in and like helps
helps define it even more so and and
really like clarify why it's funny
[Music]